- We're going to release the
chakras, starting with the top,
the second, the third,
the fourth, the fifth,
the sixth, the seventh,
and then the...
(breathing loudly)
- Bro!
We gotta hit up Nothing.
- I don't know what that means.
- No, Nothing, it's
the most popping club
in L.A., dude,
everyone knows that.
- The club's called Nothing?
- Come on, man,
name's are played out.
Anyway, I met this
dude at the weed shop,
he got me on the list plus
one tonight, and we're going.
- Bro, I've gotta focus,
man, I can't go out
getting shitfaced,
what if Amy calls me
for an emergency
audition and I'm hungover
and I throw up all over
Tarantino, then I'm fucked.
- Okay, well I see Tarantino
out all the time, dude,
so it's good to be social,
it's called networking.
Actors, directors,
producers, they're all
out shaking babies
and kissing dicks.
- If I'm at a club and
I see a baby or anybody
kissing a dick, I'm
gonna kill myself.
- You need to get laid.
How long's it been?
- Who cares?
- Not since you
moved to L.A., huh.
- Yeah, because I'm
focused on my dream, Rick.
- Bro, I want you to
succeed, this is your dream,
and it's like yeah, I wanna
keep living out here too.
Eventually find my dream.
It ain't in a Iowa cornfield.
We moved to Hollywood.
Let's fuckin' live in Hollywood.
- That's a good point,
man, Tarantino, though?
- Yes.
- I do miss boobs.
- You deserve 'em, two of 'em.
(upbeat music)
- Hope my boy put
us on the list.
- I thought you said
we were on the list.
- Well yeah, I didn't follow
up or anything, he's not
responding to any of my
texts, so that's a good sign.
Hey, what's up, man?
- Yo, name.
- Rick Marcuzzi, plus one.
- [Bouncer] That's a cool dance.
Alright I got a
Marcuzzi, no plus one.
- What?
- [Bouncer] You don't
have a plus one.
- Oh, you don't recognize him.
- No.
- Gary Scalzo, Game of Thrones
season 12, the
final arc, he played
the Raven's dad at the
Battle of Gargamill.
- There's only six seasons
of Game of Thrones.
There's no way this
little guy's an actor.
- Oh yeah I am, I'm on season 69
of How I Fucked Your Mother.
- Now both of you guys
aren't getting in.
- Oh no, what do we do now?
- Have a nice night, you guys.
- Eat my shit.
(upbeat music)
- [Rick] Season 69, dude
that was so fuckin' funny.
- What a dick door
guy, it's like
you can't even let
in one more dude?
That's insane, it's like,
you're just standing
in front of a door,
that's all you're doing,
there's no degree for
that, you know what I mean,
like anybody can
buy a clipboard, I
can buy a clipboard,
it wasn't given to
you by a wizard,
it's not a special
thing, like fuck you,
you dickless fuck stick.
- [Woman] Who is that?
- Oh, hello.
Babies.
- Holy shit.
- I'm going in.
- Tell 'em that I
worked out awhile ago.
I mean, that's so hot.
(screaming)
Oh hey, sup.
- He looks like a potato!
- No, he's a great human.
(upbeat music)
- You wanted boobs, I got
you eight, five are real.
Just breathe and throw
that Gary game, player.
- Gary's here.
(upbeat music)
Those tacos were good, right?
- Yeah they were great,
do you have any more coke?
- No I don't do coke.
- Of course you don't.
It's fine.
- Maybe we could
get some more tacos.
- What, so I can
snort some taco meat?
Fuckin' idiot.
- [Woman] This is my profile.
- Oh, these are all selfies.
- Yeah, but I have different
eyeliner on in each one.
- Oh, right, that's
to distract people
from your lazy eye right,
so they don't notice it.
- Excuse me?
- Yeah, that one's like weird.
- So he basically got me VIP
afterwards and I was like,
"Ugh, what do I look
like, a poor person?"
'Cause only poor people get
VIP, you know what I'm saying?
So I met this other promoter
who got me Artist Guest
and took me to see Calvin
Harris who was so dope.
Who was your favorite
at Coachella this year?
- At Coachella?
- Yeah.
- I didn't go.
- You don't like Coachella?
- No.
- Ugh, I was totally
gonna fuck you.
- I love Coachella, I love it.
- [Rick] Serious, I lobbed
up all those babies for you.
- I know man, I'm
a little rusty.
- Rustier than the tin man
suckin' a waterfall's dick.
Okay just repeat
this really loudly.
- What Rick, we have too much
molly, I guess just throw it
away or give it to
like a homeless family.
(screams)
- [All] No, no, no.
- Oh you guys want some?
I smell some fresh genitals.
- [Woman] Ew it's that
guy who hates Coachella,
he's the worst.
- Gary, why don't
you go grab a joint.
Lighten up the mood, huh?
- [Woman] Yeah, go.
- Alright alright, lighten
it up, let's do it.
(upbeat music)
- Hey it's locked.
(women exclaiming)
Door's locked.
Joint patrol is here!
- [Rick] Oh fuck yeah,
right there, right there.
Hey, it's Gary.
(upbeat music)